Oh straight white men am i right but
your your sister no ah you participated
in a trolling cliche one degree of
separation so you're a straight white
woman and that makes you uncomfortable
because you're just a whoa away from
being a straight white man you're only
one rung down on the privileged pyramid
so what do you do so you go to
Bangladesh to help orphans do you give
all your money to the n-double-a-cp
no of course not you log on and start
talking about straight white men
hoping that all the people of color in
the world will scream we knew you were
one of the good ones
but you're not you're one of the
annoying ones and I'm the right guy to
tell you that because I'm a straight
white man
[Music]